how long has it been since he had flesh
under his fingers too long that much was
certain this cell was small too small by
far he did not much mind being alone
that was not the issue he had long since
pulled out from himself those parts
which required company know what
bothered him was that he had nothing at
all to do his jailers would come and
speak to him from time to time certainly
but if he ever even suggested that he
may improve them by means of his craft
they'd get all in a huff and leave silly
ignorant creatures all of them but what
else could be expected of them truly it
was not their fault they were simply
very ill a shame they would not let him
cure them well there wasn't much he
could do about it at the moment might as
well return to his work he laid down on
his narrow bunk and covered himself with
his robe it was especially proud of the
robe his jailers asked about it multiple
times but whenever he tried to explain
it to them he could tell they didn't
believe him what was so odd about a robe
grafted from your own skin wasn't that
what skin was for in the first place but
all they did was moan and complain about
how it wasn't possible how no one could
remove so much skin from himself and
still live that no one even had that
much skin in the first place
showed what they knew was he not a
professional it was so difficult getting
people to show the proper respect
nowadays his mind was wandering again
what was he doing ah yes with long
well-trained fingers he began digging
into his abdomen the flesh there was
yielding properly pores neatly organized
now where did he leave his bone saw
oh yes the liver cavity reach about over
there and ah there it was hmm
the thing was getting dull and he had no
idea where he was gonna get a new one
never mind that for now he reminded
himself next the scalpels the long ones
were stashed within the bones of his
pelvis and he had a devil of a time
getting them out of there he really
needed to find a better place for them
but his body only had so much room and
any size increasing modification were
bound to be too easily noticed in his
current surrounding perhaps a second
cranial compartment something to
consider after he was finished with his
procedure he was forgetting something he
was certain of that but what was it he
dug out his dwindling supply of
adhesives from within his left eye
socket this required the temporary
removal of the eye which didn't make the
task any easier still when he was done
he had all he required to continue
spreading his robe more evenly on his
body and positioning the hem of it to
support his neck he began the operation
proper this one was going to be
difficult in order to reach that part of
his brain that he wished to remove today
he'd have to bypass some rather
essential segments failure to do so may
result in severe harm to his memory
which would obviously be catastrophic
considering he had no access to his old
fallback brain anymore not that he would
switch to that old one anyway he had
modified this new one over a period of
at least three decades and he was not
about to let all that work go to waste
though he would simply need to be
careful and that was all there was to it
when it comes to the lady whose marriage
is not sound but who makes you sniff and
prey like a hound he humped to himself
as he used the bone saw to slowly remove
the top of his skull he wasn't quite
sure where he learned that little ditty
but it soothed him he hummed on as he
laid the saw to the side and brushed off
the bone dust from his shoulders
and beauty will do you no good he
reached for his long scalpel and
maneuvered it around to that part of his
brain he hated it will not matter if you
alight onward carefully he dislodged it
from the surrounding brain matter hoping
that his incisions were precise enough
it will be good to have a mirror if
success is what do you wish and to gain
good health he finished with the scalpel
and grabbed his tweezers which he
previously retrieved from a pocket of
empty flesh around his ankles all you
need to show her is a good bit of wealth
a righteous pluck and he was done he
stopped himself for a moment what did he
feel he considered the notion of color
did he have any preference he remembered
he was always oddly fond of yellow and
despised orange with all of his heart
strange was it not the two were so very
similar to one another after all there
was no sense in it not at all he
remembered the day he finally found his
solution when he finally realized the
source of his problems all of their
problems this senseless preference and
all that was similar to them those were
the key
so did he still liked yellow yellow
yellow I don't care about yellow
capital he had done it it was gone
another wretched part of him cleansed
another remnant of the life he once
possessed removed for all time he was
about to rise and perform a Mary Jake
but then remember the top half of his
skull was still missing and reconsidered
he carefully replaced it and applied the
remnants of his adhesives to it making
sure not to reapply to the seams that
firmly attached his mask to his face it
would not do for it to come off
not ever do not get distracted he
reminded himself gathering his wits he
sat down and considered the new
composition of his brain
what new insights did the removal of the
offending sentiment allow him first he
should revise the conclusion he had
already reached to figure out if those
were still sound yes so what did he know
about life that it needed curing this
was the first of his conclusion the
foundation of all that came after and
remained as solid as ever his siblings
fools that they were thought him mad for
this realization they were created to
preserve life they claimed but they were
wrong he knew the truth he figured it
out all by himself life was a burden on
those who carried its lonesome spark
upon their souls a bundle of
contradicting impulses cruel desires and
nonsensical emotions life was an ever
multiplying beast and in his profession
such creatures only had one name a
surgeon he was the surgeon he was and he
was the one to figure out what life was
what it was really all about it was so
obvious he thought as he caressed the
skin grafts that connected his face to
his long beak mask with slim delicate
fingers life was a cancer life murdered
the soul it was his responsibility as a
medical professional and a moral being
to excise it he remembered his first
operation of the type his patients
screamed and moaned for the
anesthesiologist was not there to assist
him as he cured them from their mortal
coil the suffering was lamentable but
necessary for once they died their true
soul was revealed
this was what made him confident of the
righteousness of his cause once they
rose again cured and whole all they
desired was to help their fellows reach
the same enlightenment the soul he found
not only desired death for itself but
for the world as well to see the dead
emancipate the living that made it all
worth it all the mockery all the hatred
and loathing all his solitude he was the
he was not alone anymore two figures
stood in his bare cell staring down at
him where he laid the first was tall
gaunt dark and pale he knew him well
Lord surgeon it has been too long the
surgeon did not understand too long we
are never apart Lord I am the instrument
of your will I am with you always his
Lord said nothing only smiled the
surgeon turned his gaze to the other
figure a short stooped man who refused
to look at him directly even without his
mask the surgeon knew who he was
brother diagnostician you are no brother
of mine beast the man turned his Lord
let's get this over with his Lord nodded
then turned to the surgeon once more I
have a task for you most loyal servant
your expertise is required what what do
you desire Lord what can I do for once o
mighty the small death grinned showing
teeth like a row of tombstones why dear
sir
I have a world for you to cure